best and worst moments of the Texas GOP
debate that is all they're asking them
to do is to disable the stove the
self-destruct mode or the Ottawa race
mode on one phone in the entire world
but apple doesn't want to do it because
they think it hurts their brand well let
me tell you their brand is not superior
to the national security of the United
States of America the government wants
Apple to help the FBI get into an iPhone
by creating a tool that could compromise
everyone's security should it fall into
the wrong hands yet not a single
Republican came to the defense of Apple
or its customers yes Apple should be
forced to comply with this court order
the president United States should be
convening a meeting should have convened
a meeting with apple and our security
forces and then you know what you do
when you're the president you lock the
door and you say you're not coming out
till you reach an agreement
[Music]
the wall just got 10 feet taller believe
me we've got 10 feet tall Donald Trump's
wall keeps getting huger and huger but
even the notion of a trade war with
Mexico won't stop him in fact he kind of
likes the idea of consumers getting
caught in the cross streams of an
intergovernmental pissing contest you
know I don't mind trade wars well we're
losing fifty eight billion dollars a
year you want to know the truth and one
of trumps worst moments of the night was
perfectly punctuated by his fake offense
at former Mexican President Vicente
Fox's salty language I'm not going to
fail you for that [ __ ] wall this guy
used a filthy disgusting word on
television and he should be ashamed of
himself and he should apologize because
we all know Donald Trump is known for
keeping it classy this is you
[ __ ] they knock the [ __ ] out of
everybody in less than five years
eighty-three percent of our entire
budget will be made up of Social
Security Medicare Medicaid and the
interest on the debt amid this elections
talk of bombing raids and greek-style
social welfare one thing has been
missing the price tag give Rubio some
credit for hitting us with some sticker
shock this debt issue is weird the next
president the United States will not be
able to serve for 28 years without
dealing with the national debt it is not
a question of if it is a question of
when we have a debt crisis at least he
brought it up because we know how much
mr. Trump hates talking about money if
you eliminate completely the department
of education as you have proposed that's
about sixty eight billion dollars if you
eliminate the Environmental Protection
Agency that's about eight billion
dollars that's about 76 billion dollars
for those two agencies the current
deficit this year is 544 billion dollars
where are you going to come up with
money fraud and abuse all over the place
waste your
antabuse what is your plan I understand
the lines around the state whatever that
means this is not a game where you draw
mad you don't know what what is your
quiet the brother second best moment
came when Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz
revealed to the audience that Donald
Trump's health care plan isn't really a
plan but I will not allow people to die
on the sidewalks and the streets of our
country if I'm president you may let it
and you may be finally the government
I'm not earlier we are going to take
yester evil and they're going to get a
question excuse me you're the only
person on the stage that's ever been
fined for hiring people to work on your
projects illegal you hired some more I'm
the only one of the sage has hired
people you haven't hired anybody Trump
has built his political career on
stoking fear of border crossers so the
best moment of the night was this
full-throated defense of hiring illegal
immigrants when he's the one doing you
could not get help it's the up season
everybody agrees with me on that they
were part-time jobs you need them or we
just might as well close the doors
because you couldn't get help in those
hot hot sections of Florida but at least
Trump's still fighting the good fight to
keep one Canadian from getting a great
American job Donald relax I'm relaxed
you're than a banjo case go ahead go
ahead don't get noobs mark patrolman I'm
wing is my answer he doesn't get to
heaven whoops I want to move on these
are the rules we're looking on you know
I you get the whole time
you want to get a response you'll have
your do I Dolores
[Music]